[Musique]
la FRCA le département de La Réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la Réunion vous
présente terre
[Musique]
d'ici véritablement passionné pour cette
culture originale installé ligne des 400
au tampon George Saver s'est lancé voici
une dizaine d'années dans la production
de ce fruit d'un cactus originaire
d'Amérique centrale le pitaya quand j'ai
été appelé au sirad pour plus ou moins
voir ce que c'était la pita ben je suis
tombé directement amoureux de tout ça
quoi je me suis dit ben c'est c'est une
plante d'avenir c'est un fruit d'avenir
c'est beau c'est c'est c'est tout ce
qu'on veut on on fait des glaces
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui avec he c'est
c'est ouais voilà c'est c'est devenu une
passion entre guillemets on peut la
planter de de du bord de mer jusqu'à
très haut mais à 400 m je pense que
c'est déjà c'est c'est une très bonne
altitude pour le pour la pitaa pas trop
chaud et pas trop
frais également bien exposé au soleil
les rangs de pitaya sont plantés sur du
palissage des supports grillagés qui
facilitent leur entretien et pour
apporter à ces cactus tous les éléments
nécessaires George utilise uniquement du
fumier de
depuis le départ amendement organique
plus paillage pour pas que le fumier se
dessèche et pourut pas
que pour pas que la la plante
subisse subisse de stress quoi
voilà grâce à tous ces soins et
notamment une taille annuelle des plants
les pitayas vont alors offrir une
floraison abondante des fleurs qui
s'épanouissent le soir venu et qu'il
faut donc polliniser de nuits une à une
à la
main on a les étamines avec le pollen et
puis au milieu on a le pistile ok donc
euh le pollen se dépose sur le pistile
et qui va aux organes reproducteurs qui
se trouent en bout de en bout de pestile
quoi et après le fruit se développe la
fleur tombe la pollisation vient de deux
espèces hein de la variété rouge et de
la variété blanche le pollen se met euh
se met vice-versa dans le pisile ouais
il faut les il faut les croiser et à
partir de là on a un fruit à cher rouge
et un fruit à chair blanche à partir de
moment la polinisation est faite euh il
se passe un mois une semaine et le fruit
est bon à être récolteré à cette
altitude une précision et une régularité
du développement du fruit qui facilite
les prévisions de récolte du producteur
des fruits pays de qualité excellents
également pour la santé bon ben je pense
que demain demain ou après-demain je
pense que c'est ça sera bon à être
récolté quoi donc là elles ont bien pris
une belle couleur donc bientôt ouis
fruits fermes bon il y a pas forcément
de la grosseur mais elles sont fermes
donc je pense que ça ira la ch un
complexe comp vitaminé elle contient de
beaucoup d'antioxydants donc je pense
que c'est ça qui qui tient à cœur pas
mal de gens elle ne contient pas
énormément de sucre donc tous ceux qui
sont diabétiques et cetera qui ne
peuvent plus forcément manger des fruits
c'està-dire mnéti et cetera parce que
contion de sucre est énorme
ben ils ont ils devrai se pencher sur
sur la
[Musique]
pita fruit de l'été très apprécié pour
ses qualités rafraîchissantes le pitaya
se consomme frais bien sûr et même glacé
maître artisan glacier Stéphane soulier
crée avec tout son savoir-faire des
sorbets à base de fruits pays comme ce
jour-là avec ces pitaya alors je vais
préparer un sorbet pitaya avec des
pitayas de Monsieur Sauveur qui est qui
a donc une exploitation sur le tampon la
ligne des 400 donc voilà on va préparer
on va couper les pitaya les
préparer c'est les pitailla violette
j'utilise des pita Violett simplement
pour Ben la couleur je trouve qu'elles
sont un petit peu plus goûteuses et elle
donne une couleur rose fuchia qui est
qui est superbe par rapport à la blanche
qui est un petit peu plus notutre et
puis mais la couleur moins attractive la
fabrication du sorbet se poursuit après
avoir coupé les pitailla en deux Stéphan
en récupère la pulpe fraîche et
naturellement très coloré on récupère la
pulpe et le jus les deux et ensuite on
va broyer broyer grossièrement le le
fruit pour le pulper en fait c'est un
fruit qui est très facile à travailler
contrairement à à certains autres la
mangue est plus plus compliqué la pitaya
c'est quand même un fruit assez assez
facile à trill à travailler c'est c'est
le fruit c'est un des fruits que je
préfère travailler oui il y en a
d'autres qui sont un peu plus
contraignants comme dans toutes mes
glaces ou l'essentiel de mes glaces je
rajoute je ne rajoute pas de pas de
colorant et pas de pas d'arôme il faut
cependant encore rajouter le bon dosage
de sirop de sucre pour obtenir la base
du sorbet le sorbet c'est avant tout du
fruit dans une proportion la plus haute
possible technologiquement et ensuite
simplement du sucre et de l'eau voilà
pour équilibrer un petit peu la formule
c'est
tout la transformation de la préparation
en sorbet peut alors commencer alors là
je mets le mélange qu'on vient de faire
dans la turbine donc la turbine c'est
simplement un appareil qui transforme ce
ce mix ce mélange euh à un sorbé donc il
va refroidir et incorporer un petit peu
un petit peu d'air en même temps il
refroidit très vite
après quelques minutes passées dans la
machine le sorbet opitaya est enfin prêt
c'est pas une crème glacée c'est un
sorbet donc pas de pas de lait pas de
matière grasse et effectivement j'ai une
j'ai des des sorbets qui ont une texture
relativement crémeuse bon c'est
simplement dans la proportion des des
ingrédients et savoir-faire du du
glacier avec une couleur fuchia qui qui
donne envie et qui est qui est 100 %
naturelle puisquelle n'est donnée que
par que par le fruit ce qui attire en
tout premier lieu c'est la couleur donc
surtout les enfants bon ils
assimilissent un petit peu à la fraise
et euh bon ça ça attire vraiment ça
attire vraiment l'œil l' pitaillage j'en
fait pas toute l'année j'en fais un
saison voilà donc voilà c'est un fruit
un peu plus saisonnier pour moi une
petite sauce des petits
topines et elle est
[Musique]
prête